Today's guest was the German, globally
successful, adult entrepreneur Sheldon
Rogue,
for example, also completely unfair,
actually, how much I earn, so
I find it sometimes looks like that in
my income, and I should
think that's actually so
unbelievably terrible, not
done again this month  where I
haven't actually done anything
I always feel the need to show people
what's going wrong
because there's
often something like yes and if you
want to earn money but still
want to remain anonymous hey you can
also great without a face
[music]
probably make two 300 girls a day,
some of them girls who probably
don't even know if they
're of legal age at all girls who are maybe
just 18 and do
n't even know where their journey should
go and then  you offer
something like that so it's not somehow
the no idea there  s is
thrown somewhere outside don't know any
veils will be distributed because we're
looking for help in the ice cream parlor but
it's still about money Appointment
with his own body
[applause]
welcome to the OMR podcast
Philipp Westermeier
I've just been in the announcer of adult
entrepreneur  spoken you could also
say of course it's about
pornography a porn creator that's
perfectly clear we're talking about the
biggest porn platforms in the world
pornhub infinitely soon it's
already in the name where the Shane
Rogue he is traveling and where she is ahead of
everyone  Things are very big,
that's unusual because this
platform is simply huge and
since you can rarely talk to people at all
and certainly not with
German people, global business and
now we have a young lady
who talked a lot about it and yes  also
told in German which is always
helpful you have to auc  h say during the
podcast I was primarily concerned, of
course, as always here, with the
whole economic side, with the
effects of how this platform works, in
the end there are also large social
networks now with followerships
and blue ticks and all the trimmings
that do it  you might not be
so clear then in the conversation but
I noticed that sometimes I
really winced at how crass it
is what is happening behind the scenes
that you just don’t know,
maybe what then became really clear to me in the conversation
it's
partly yes, but I didn't think
about it, there were also really
abusive situations that were described to me
about the damage, of
course I still tried to
focus on the economic issues, as I'm still used
to,
we still have a little longer
phoned the situation explained a
bit on the record I find it
t  nevertheless very very impressive also
very worrying what happened there
I am very happy for her that she came out so
well I think it is
also important to understand that and
to present it here accordingly and
the chance you have that someone
talks openly about it  to
offer oneself here is already a
very crass business not in the sense of
economically successful that in large
parts yes but also at very
considerable yes costs for
people somehow maybe for
society I have
to form an opinion here I yes myself
the thoughtful
left behind also decide the specific case
that turned out well but I
think it could have gone quite differently
there are still a few
messages that, for example,
your career was over when you were over
I don't think anyone really understood
it became clear to me from a podcast that
we included this here, so to speak
in that sense now get into the conversation with
Jane Rock let's go
welcome nice hi thanks for letting
me be there so Sheldon Rogue
I guessed that correctly is not
your real name that's absolutely not
my real name and how you real name
is that  is of course not known
yes I think just
protect them a bit yourself and if you reveal so
much then at least
understand a bit of privacy then yes
it is known what your
career was like I mean I
just said you are on
one now  of the largest pore platforms in the
world very successfully then you
haven’t uploaded that many videos
in total, so at least according to
my feeling I don’t have a
great idea right now but it seems to me that
for at least my normal social
media conditions there are few videos
how it went  it's up to you where are you from
I've never said where
I originally  come from at the beginning of
my career i always said
i came from hamburg because that was
just right because i was far away from
it but i originally come
from saxony-anhalt and i
grew up there but
i moved to leipzig when i was 16 i did your
apprenticeship as
I became a physiotherapist and after I finished that I
waited briefly and then
it slowly started that I then um
then ventured into the Internet how
how is the access I mean
in the waitress from Leipzig is
not the same as it is now  how did that come about no when
how that came so came did it through
my boyfriend at
the time he practically brought
me in okay okay so you found it
interesting or you actually
just said
yes well you can say yes would like
now after the breakup thinks
of course a bit
different than at the time when
it all started, I'm of course glad
that I did  I did everything like this in the
end because I now have a
very, very nice life and can
fulfill my dreams again but of course you
ask the question whether I would have done that too
if I hadn’t
met him and I would answer
I think no but okay
what exactly does it mean, so you recorded
porn videos with you at the
beginning and then uploaded them, yes,
not directly from day one, but
it was clear from day 1 hour that he was
very interested in it and
also did it with his ex-partner
but it worked out for each other blah blah and
then it was just such a
gradual process that I
said no if I didn’t because I
was still a bit in my
parental
cosmos because of the training here
and then working meant 5 then you are
you're retiring but so stop and of
course you also
think a bit about what the
environment says
but nonetheless  otz I was always such
an open person and when I was
never such a little wallflower
or someone who somehow
hid or was afraid of the outside world
or of something not
to draw attention to when and it
just stood there at the beginning  not
really sure yet that I'm going to do it,
but I was just like that, do it
because we also had an open
relationship, and then I said yes, I
'll do your bookkeeping or
just do the girls' make-up, which we
then somehow invite and shoot  and
at some point we just
sat together with all the business
from mydirty hobby is just the largest
German internet platform
in the subject of porn and
at that time the plan was that I
would take part but without a face and
he said you can do that
but without you
wanting to attack your face in some way is
actually what could really
pop and then we have such an egg  A
bit of chatter then I was okay,
come on,
try it, and then you
uploaded videos to
mydeutsche hobby at the beginning
, right at the beginning, two or three months
before the videos came, we
were
more or less here on chaturbate  known simply with a
live webcam did a bit of
our stuff to see how it works for
us or how it suits me whether
I feel comfortable there or
not and I
actually liked it quite a bit and then
at some point we just moved on  gone
too
times through hobby and
manyvets and so the gaming
platform that somehow
doesn't exist yet pornhub and co but
first things where
it's a bit more
encrypted and not so
public where you have to be registered of course
and then also have to search a bit
and because at the very
beginning there was of course still the gap between
Sheldon Rogue and  nd Sheldon Rogue was on
the chaturbate the girl which
was used a bit harder,
so to speak, but the damage to my
hobby there where it built up a
bit there I was at the beginning the
shy girl from Hamburg had just
turned 18 Max Herde really doll and
has never undressed in front of the camera
and that's why you're
still called Schaden because
we didn't want it to be found like
that because who wouldn't have been a good start
I would have gone straight to my first
video like that
but on such sites  do you need
it a bit more slowly
and yes, that's how it went,
so I quickly became
one of the
most successful well-known at MyDirtyHobby, as you
would like to call it, and I mean
, what did you do differently
than the others there  there isn't
a small platform, so
I've often been told that it's
just because of this
skill, it's just because
But now I think I was
just in the right place at the right time,
so I just signed up on the
one day I
did what was recommended to me from
the
uploads of the videos and maybe I
don’t have this typical German clientele
Dirty Talk and  colorful headings
packed somewhere in the thumbnail
but I was I was I think
just a bit different I took
off a bit with it but I
still think it was more of a
coincidence than that I
'm somehow super great but I
mean you did  shot these these videos
with your
boyfriend at the time, so to speak, who was then your
partner in front of the camera, so to speak, are right
there my partner in front of the camera, who was also my partner in front of the camera
in most of the videos,
because
I actually had little interest in
either  other people there
a few times there were of course where
I then yes I want to shoot n  I didn't have to say
but
it was kind of intentional
that it's obviously more lucrative
when he's seen by someone else and
so
and then there are a
few videos maybe let me just
three four maybe five where
we  can be seen differently or then the
genital area like the face but
otherwise everything was with my partner at the time
and that was quite
fine with me. The last video I shot was
about a year ago but I mean
you are already making your ad again, so to speak
oh so my beginners were
in
February 2019 oh so not
that long you are and you are now in your
mid-20s no I'm running I'm
still 18 it
's happening from year to year in
truth I'm of course a bit older
like  old exactly, of course you
don't know that exactly, but I
'm definitely in my 20s,
okay, that means you just
talked a bit about the thumbnails
is somehow
Of course you also think about platform optimization
intensively so what do I write
in the thumbnail as it
probably so that the the first
picture well I imagine I
probably thought about it even more
on such a platform than
on Instagram or on a normal
platform because  since there is so much
choice and you are always looking for new people and you
want to stand out somehow
exactly yes and especially with metal the hobby
is often so that you
want to stand out you use a
thumbnail which is somehow particularly
provocative although on his  side
is not very provocative and then
I
somehow put a lot of stuff in the
sample in neon green or purple and then hope that it will catch my
eye, but
because everyone does it I can
imagine that my videos would be punished
because I  I just didn't write anything in there
, so there was nothing and that was it
just me it seemed like just
me as a young girl and you built
up a small community relatively quickly that was
at the start of every video and that
happened naturally and you chatted with them, so to speak, or
did it exist with them  Exchange or or was it
just like that, you some anonymous
people watch it and think you're cool
and just watch everything you do, they
are interested in
somehow writing with the actresses
and
so many people sometimes confuse it
with a dating platform like that
meet where I thought
no, not really, I don't want to meet up
with anyone from the internet
,
but yes, exactly, of course, there is
the possibility that you somehow come up with
a piece of paper that costs
so and so many coins for a message
and that  but so I would say
I would say more than
half take that definitely sold as  o
to have a bit of a closer connection to the
favorite actress, that means
you ended up
becoming the favorite portrayal for many people,
you can
say I, well, I assume I've read it
a few times, of course, but
I am, I am  the person who
somehow got the right out of it even so
yes I know for X people the
favorite actress I don't
know I was definitely one that you
liked to look at which I think you
can understand quite well from the numbers
but I would now  don't say
that I somehow have no idea
a super great one if she
somehow impressed every white person with the
video and how big was that then how
many people
watched it because back then I looked at it again through
the numbers of
are gigantic
yes yes the hobby was of course
in no way on such a large
scale but
yes you could say that
depending on  Video has already taken several
thousand and
with my hobby, for example,
you have to actively look up how many
sales it has and can be seen at the front
because of that, but you I had you can
both see the hobby the
reviews so you can see how many
People have rated it and so you can
calculate it so flat-
rate I think they bought
it and based on these ratings
I already had the feeling that I
tended to have sold more, but
it may also be because I
didn’t chat so much
normal ones that are maybe exclusive on this page, they
upload
twice a week sometimes
four times a week and if you
count it on a month, that's
sometimes 16 videos
where of course you always
bring something new somewhere  must and I can
imagine that if someone does not
upload quite as much or
the users somehow get three M  waiting for a long time in the
foot video and after three
months you finally do your feet again
then of course everyone falls on it and
because I have the feeling that it’s just
because of it and tell me what can you
do with a video like that, so
you decide  Price of what's there,
you determine the price yourself.
Everyone has to know that for themselves.
I haven't uploaded anything for a long time.
It's then calculated based on the number of
minutes, how much you
definitely have to take, and you can
then stagger that a bit  I
didn't always take the lowest
price, but something over that means
something like
that, you can calculate something like this,
don't let me lie, I'm not
quite sure anymore, but then somehow per minute
in euros or something okay,
that means if you buy it
then wanted from you then
somehow then if I paid 10 euros
for the video so that you had ten
minutes you paid about 10 euros or
just
10  0 or 1000 dirty cents or
whatever the currency, of course it's
not euros but converted to your own
currency and you
then give part of that to the site and
I get a part because my hobby is of
course a lot of what you have to give away
and on other sides rather less
like the world is so what
absolutely first 75 percent but the
absolutely bottomless really really cheeky
and at
augenlicher for example you only give
20% but why do you do that
at all if you have to give so much
because it is a  is very popular because
it is the largest German site and
because of that you are well
known because Hobby
has its own stand on the
Venus in Berlin, they are of course
huge, they have huge offices
in Cyprus and Canada
and
yes, when you are there  just kind of big is
opened up that still then still
doors to other things
hobbies you have now described then
you are obvious  moved to a next
platform
exactly after the time or during the
time I was still with the girl the hobby because
I let everything sink in more or less
equally a bit
then it started that we
I think in August
2000 Association 20 I would like to say or
even  in August 2001 I'm not quite
sure that we then also
uploaded the stuff to
pornhub, we met someone
who is also super successful with
women
and also edits for other
creators himself and also uploads one himself
own production of that kind of stuff and he
can really, really
fantastically figure out how the algorithm is there and
he has direct contacts to pornhub and
can just clarify everything
and then got in touch with us because he
somehow saw me and my stuff  hey,
I can take care of that for you so that
you become well known and I still work with him
to this day and he really does it
so well  anz great and what is the
managing director of that so you
give a bit of
the
income or 15% a month of what comes in at
pornhub so he then looks how
much I took there and then
also at so he does pornhub  x videos
and I think x hamster or something like that had
also done it
and then just look what came in
then put his bill and
I transfer that and how do you
earn yellow on pornhub because you just said
with my Tobi you have to
pay you have to  register at
asks I'm there I can have
anyone exactly that's the way it is, there were
definitely different test models up until two years ago
, so of
course I had this
free look where you got your
income from advertisements
the tub on the side is nice  what
pills or something that you can swallow
and then something gets bigger or do
n't know before the video an advertisement
for another site so Su  si live or
something should there be a stop and
that's one source of income there
you had, among other things, an extra
fan club where people could register
for x price and then had
extra clips or you watched the
video you watched  looked at it and
found it good, downloaded it for 5
dollars and then you could watch it in
offline mode or you got
extra tips that you
sent somehow the different models were like that at the
moment
I don't really know what's left of them
remained because pornhub was also
heavily criticized partly due to
various topics
and now it is definitely certain that
this free share of viewing through
advertising revenue still works,
but I believe
these, for example, these fan shop things,
I believe there are no longer any because
for you on  End of the lucrative at
pornhub anyway because the size is
so enormous or absolutely was within
ku  Recently I'm shooting
up and I don't know how many 50
60,000 people signed up and
within two weeks I was in the
top 300 and then again two weeks
later somehow in the top 15 so
it went really quickly and has one
of course happy ne but that's also
so what was the trick there to become so
big so I mean if it's supposed to be so
obviously quite a lot of people what
did that what he triggered
that not a bit under
wraps if you wanted
it all  know and
is always super super difficult
because I would then I think my
buddy and business partner the pornhub
guy who just does it for me I think
he would get a bit
headless if I could just find out
like that so there is one
would  than you have to give a two tips
what means tricks you just
have to understand the algorithm you have to understand
when exactly is best that i
upload something when wel  che is always like that
action reaction ne is just like
any other platform probably
tiktok and co or YouTube or
something else but you have to
understand that a bit and then be
ready to deliver afterwards
our partner vodafone has
the last one as so often  Years ago there was once again an
innovation, especially for
business customers, and there is now
Ring Central, a cloud-based
all-in-one
communication platform or, to
put it more simply, it is about
teams being able to work together on one
platform and then all devices, all
information, all apps, all tools  are kept in
a central cloud
that everyone can access where
it doesn't matter whether you
access it with a PC with a tablet with a
smartphone where you are who you
are this enables collaborative
work according to the requirements of
the new modern working world who
would like more information about All
in One  Communication platform that
finds everything at
vodafone.de/ring central
[music]
we're talking about 324 million views that
you've collected
so far that's
gigantic of course worldwide and what
does it lead to in the end
so I have to introduce it to me  the fact that you have
now become or are becoming a multi-millionaire
is simply
very good extra income, so to speak, or what dimensions
are we talking about
in the early days
when it was actually just further the
hobbycorn has blah blah, as things
were
around it, that was it  I was already
earning several 10,000 euros a month
when one or the other path broke
and porn was sometimes on the
verge of ruin myself and who could
no longer
cope deleted videos and I in particular who
had done harder things
the
automated
mechanism has
always taken some out because
the bot can then recognize or think
to have that is too hard so white it
was very much
in the room that many women were somehow
coerced and you would see that on their
faces and here and there which
I don't want to rule out at all there
are probably a lot of bad
people who just
push someone to do it and what  to do something that I didn't
want to do,
but despite that it was a
bit
damaging for the person who
maybe had a certain
acting talent and
looked more tormented than
tormented by the
fact that I
also had the support and then
direct access  to Korn and to
the support and to the CEO and stuff like
that, it was then also easier
to unlock
it again and then of course it was earned a little
less during the time, sometimes almost nothing at all
and then more again,
but that’s how mine have always been  a
few thousand part 10,000 that you
somehow still
earn is not that little money is
ga  nz good thing
is that in the meantime you have created an
apology for videos
or have uploaded them where you then know
okay they will definitely be
good for a while which should throw off
so you are also working towards the
fact that you have done so much that  at
some point you don't have to do it for the whole
thing anymore and you can still make a good
living from it okay and that's the case with you
so a bit like with
music there is a gentleman like that with a
permanent payment if things are
looked up exactly yes so that
as long as it is watched or bought
, there is no end, of course,
okay, but the platform doesn't
constantly demand something new, so I would have
thought that new
things come up every day and people
want to see something new, that's what the
platform itself demands
not after new stuff, of course,
but the people who access the platform are of
course already at it
, so it's clear if you like someone
looks like someone who
makes music like that rihanna has
n't uploaded an album like that for x years she
probably gets
several thousand messages a day I know bold hey
Rihanna keeps making albums
and it just came to me like when is your
next video why  If there is nothing
more
you don't even want to be here we can and
then we also think
that you have you wouldn't do anything
yes well
the thing is after I broke up with
my darling film partner and also
then
boyfriend the plan was that I  somehow continue
and then of course it was super
difficult because
far away from the dispute I
had or still have with him, you still got
along well
and you somehow knew what was
going on in the videos and
what was well received and what you had
lived together for years and that's why
we knew each other and
could talk to each other
differently and something different from an e  than with
someone who, for example, hasn’t filmed at all
or is already filming in some way,
but then in a completely different
cosmos depends on the film material what you
do because my videos
are a bit different than these
typical German videos
where there is so much  is told and where
the camera angles are not as
I would like them to be and so
on and so forth and from that it was
very, very difficult to find someone that
I
would have been happy with and would not have put in
more work than wages
and  Then I thought, hey, come on, I
'll do it a
bit quietly, make the fans happy too, because
the people and we're still learning
what we have and
[music]
then I'll do it again as soon as I
can or because I have to  it was also
a bit of a private thing to go
like this after this breakup and
so I was already
at a point where I then also fell in
love a bit too much d
turned to alcohol and not basically
because of the breakup that's over
wow well that's really a computer
in my life I'm really
very happy about it but yeah it would be
nice if a breakup just
stayed a breakup and then
everything would be fine but
maybe sometimes you got involved
with the wrong people and
that you don't express yourself and of course sometimes you try
to compensate a bit and for me it was
stupidly just the alcohol
and then there's the fact that you're natural
I also gain weight quickly somehow because of alcohol and I don’t even notice it and suddenly I had 15 kilos more and was so okay now I actually don’t want to show myself like that anymore, actually because I don’t push myself that well
anymore  and then
still had the option with the
gentleman who just managed my
gynecologist account there  how to shoot and stuff
but I thought to myself
no, don't do it at all, at least not at the
moment, but I thought as soon as
I somehow feel better
mentally physically then we'll do it
and then came the shocking
turn of events that I would find my current boyfriend
met him and also said to
him so hey watch out,
so you know what I'm doing and I
'll just keep doing it, so
either you can handle it or we
're just not a good match and
he said you can do it, it's
fine and still  that he
said that I somehow didn't see myself
able to continue in any
way because, as I said, I did
n't feel too well and
even now, at this point in time
, I would say that I'm
in an open relationship with my ex partner
was now because of the monogamous
relationship I would I would
n't think it was great if I was shooting
with someone else  In order to
somehow keep my kind of career
going, just the
idea of ​​it actually
scares me a bit
and that's why I was basically always
so right that I said I wouldn't do
anything if we just didn't fit
that's why  sometimes we didn't
work out
so well but I never got so stressed
that I said to myself okay
I have to upload twice a week somehow
because otherwise I earn
less than last month how was
it always relatively irrelevant I
just wanted more  Have fun with it
instead of taking this success and the
money and I think I
actually did quite well and
that's why I didn't have the
pressure in any way that I now absolutely
have to start shooting again because I
think to myself okay I've got it  Videos
now and I'm
still making good money from it and when I realize
that it's not  is more the
case then something else
will happen because you have to
honestly say I'm lucky that
I
just have this media presence and
can enjoy general interest in the white and
that's what
the cat in today's world is all about
So of course you have to or you can't anymore,
if you've done
one thing then you
don't have to stick to one thing anymore,
but because of this media
interest you naturally have extremely open positions
and of course I hope
so and that's why it's like this at
the moment  It's
not planned either that I'll somehow
go back there
again in that sense,
but now somehow I
'll look for something else
that could be me, I
already suspect a few things, but
tell me again that you're only fans because
you're there  you're still active or is
it over so not active that's of
course still what I have
or had but there's coming now too
you can say that it's not new anymore,
but there's still money coming out of the
old videos, so to speak, there's still good
money out there, yes, and there are
dimensions too, it's more than with pornhub
or that's very lucrative or
less that was it's more with  pornhub well
I always find it really funny
because first of all I said it the way
I said it myself I've never
said it before that's why I was
a bit cautious right now
so people don't actually know
that they don't do anything anymore, they're
always waiting  still excited that there will
be something new because I never
really announced the end of this
career
but
what should I ask again I want
fans somehow relevant for you or if there is
still so much coming out oh yes exactly
so there it comes  still nice out and
now I know what I
should be getting at, we often write
so only fans agencies on Instagram and I find them
really, really terrible u  And above all more
reprehensible because the way they write
you can tell directly that they ultimately
don’t deal with the person at all
and let’s write each other like that hey
we’ve seen your profile
and wow so you could
really become something with unifants and here under this
and that  we can
earn up to 10,000 euros within a very short time
or and then I always say to
people you pretend to be
an agency and you don't
want to sell someone something good and you
fail with the first sentence, so how
can it be somehow related
or together  fit if I do
n't manage to enter the name on Google beforehand like this,
someone
writes it doesn't work
like that, you can't give up a serious
agency agency somehow,
maybe 400,000 or even more will be
lost, I mean, there'll
probably be quite a lot coming in then
there's a lot coming in but well, these are
things that annoy me  tremendous
that I really I always feel the
need to show people what's
going wrong somehow because there
's often something like yes and
if you want to earn money
but still want to remain anonymous hey
you can do that really well without  make face
actually you should probably write that a
day 2 300 girls
partly girls who maybe
don't even want to know if they
are of legal age at all
girls who are maybe just
18 and don't even
know where their healing journey should go
and then offers  you put that on so it
's not somehow that no idea
that's being advertised somewhere out there do
n't know any flyers are being
distributed because we're looking for temporary workers in the
ice cream parlor but it's still
about making money with your own
body and that's always the case  it's
still the internet and as much as I
smiled at my parents back then when they
said the internet doesn't forget
and once it's in there you can't get out, all the
more so it's
somehow
a bit more worrying because
I think it's easier to say yes, especially at a
young age, instead of having
thought about it and
I think that's what it is  It's really nice when I'm because
I'm finding porn nudity or
just some other things
that go in this direction that
shouldn't be done because you
see quick money but if you
're at peace with
yourself you're kind of beautiful yourself  finds knows
what you are doing and, above all, has become
aware of what that means for the
future, for example if you
have a degree and have no idea
your biggest dream is somehow really
big in New York, just to become a judge at
some point in Germany  Although
a degree but do not know what you still
a foreign country somehow in the USA and
something here
then the chances are there  ss you are really
successful there but rather worse
if you then at some point have stood naked
broadband somewhere in front of some
camera and I find that
somehow always so great reprehensible
simple but
would you do it again so now in hindsight
now what now  just said at the beginning
that is not so clear to you so a
little bit the whole year
so I yes I said if I
would have done it like that on my own I would say
no
if I would do it like that again now
maybe but you can be very precise
I can't say that, but I just
have a better view of
it now and
I was just like that when I was a teenager,
so I was just very, very
open with everything and I liked to show myself
a bit that I
stood up  I like being the center of attention and that
's why the scene or
the industry has never offended me in
any way or anyone else  s
done nothing not negative and more
it doesnt hurt now in
hindsight that theres some stuff
from the internet because i have
no problem with nudity and
yes and i think also have
very very good self esteem
when dealing with messages like no idea if
i somehow  upload a picture with my friends
and then it comes like he
just kissed the whole of Germany like that like a
complete man are just I get along
with it very very well but
I also did it because I had to that
I didn’t want to do it somehow for the
money but me  I would like to
build up something long-term
and I think many of them
just can’t do that before a young girl
because when you somehow came along you’re just
18 maybe you still have an apprenticeship,
then the money is somehow
always tight and if someone then
writes you, you have no idea  he
just takes a few pictures of the feet
and sells them, but there's nothing there,
what are they anyway  ch Schuessler so then tell
me I'll find it faster just like
that yes instead of having to really
think about it something that comes after
that just start with your feet or what what
comes next I have no idea
the bottom or
bare upper body or underwear or
something but it's still going
on and I think even if someone
did it out of conviction at the beginning,
sometimes the boundaries blur,
because then you might see that okay,
I've earned it quite well,
but
it's super, super difficult, I have
now noticed that in the last few
months
you have been doing more and more mainstream things, so you
talk to us about that, you were with Reso, you were in
a different
podcast, so now it’s not porn, but
really more normal things
, that’s going to be a bit your way  it's
also just like being a normal
influencer that with us I've now
seen that you deleted all the photos except
for  So one thing I think what you were
planning
on Instagram was that thing I
had a little god intervention and
then it became free, my
account was blocked and when I
reactivated
it it was so that somehow suddenly
everything was just gone so I have to  also
not somehow all all messages
away that I ever had and also all
pictures and anything else
that's because I
activated it too late or something else I
don't know exactly where it came from
but
after it was unlocked again
I practically gave myself another
two or three
weeks because I realized when my
Instagram account was gone that
wasn't such a shock for me, so I
wasn't sad
about it at all or I thought oh my god now
somehow everything I
built up is gone, maybe that's
because they don't make any money on Instagram
, but I h  But I had the
feeling that I had
a
little more peace in my life without this social media Instagram thing
and yes, distributed is simply
reactivated too late and that's why everything was
gone that's why there's only
one picture
at the moment but with the others so podcast  and been to
some Youtubers and so
that was all a lot last year,
actually, even when I was
out and about a little more, I
was actually held back a bit in the time before that
,
always with the statement not that I was
putting anyone in the wrong light,
whether that would happen then  was like that or whether that was
actually the intention behind the
statement as I actually
dare to doubt today but after I was then
free in quotation marks I of
course simply accepted many invitations
because I also knew if
I could be seen somewhere else then
we could  that
maybe still benefit that someone then
not yet  fully subscribed or
some videos are coming so you
mainly I did that of
course because I just
wanted to travel around a bit somehow have fun
to meet new people
but at the end of the day it is of course
not entirely without
ulterior motives of course not because when
the group is on Mykonos  chills and
celebrates and also
makes some blogs then it's
not just we want you or I
want to show my community how
great the vacation is but of course you know
that it will be well clicked and
then maybe he'll step in
or other pennies but
with you now okay I
understood that so I would have been completely different now I
would have thought much more strategically
but that you do it consciously in
order to position yourself in relation to others or
something like
that it sounds more like it
Mixture of enjoying life and traffic
for for for for the frontpla  ttform but
it is already clear to you where
your journey is going so now you
thought that one is over for now so
a bit you have a new
relationship I think you are with
the youtuber but
with the stream you have oranges  orange
together yes so what's the plan so
are there any considerations of a
professional nature so how is it going for you
nope so actually not so far but
as I said I do
n't put any pressure on myself because I'm just
lucky and I'm the way I am  so
incredibly happy that I do
n't have to put any pressure on myself, so I'm
not a person who somehow lives beyond their means
where I should just
say God if I continue like this
then in three months
I'll have eaten a shift in the box but I
[music  ]
I think I can pat myself
on the back a bit that
I dribbled well and
invested my money well and wi  e
said, well,
something comes in every month and I just see where
the path leads me so if I
have no idea
at some point I think like yes I'll start
with tiktok now does he do something like that and
then it works then it
'll be that or if if I  I kind of think hey,
I don't know, I want to do
another
apprenticeship because I'm super interested in the
subject, then I would do it too,
because in the end it's still
about me and if I can
do it then I'll be better off  does or better does
something else to do far away from
somewhere then I'll just do it
and then it doesn't give a
[ __ ] if I then
earn
something normal again a few words about tiktok because I
think that would actually be a
channel where people suspect you too  would
but you're doing
very little right now and then you look in from
time to time but what do you think
that I don't have anything that's
because I don't  ssbar lazy and at the same
time very self-critical
means
annoyed about the situation was that
I'm not happy with it that I often
thought that he would
just hand out nothing at all for others
it probably wouldn't have noticed at all
but
I know I think it's about time  long
also persuaded that everything always has to look so
perfect and licked and super great
so that no one
can attack anything in any way, that
means the same
desire for perfection that exists at the grain platforms also
you didn’t just
set up a camera then, which I present
and then there and that's just a huge
set, a huge production, at the end the
camera set up and get started
that has little
to do with the real world, of course,
which many people forget,
but it was
a pure
staging, of course, that
doesn't happen  Postman of course or otherwise
yes of course but it's just t
Despite that, I can or did I have the feeling
in the past that many
don't want to think that far,
maybe um and then really think that he is
the cousin because the girl then
wrote yes and that was really
my cousin nope and that too
in 90  % of the cases it's not more
unknown somewhere because people
still have to sign a
contract because otherwise you
shouldn't be able to upload it at all, so you can
be sure that
something happened by accident, but
we're going to describe it at a
porn shoot like this  that somehow
then also how to get together
maybe a porn film and the 8
9 10 people, so to speak, camera people light
and everything back on the set then right yes
exactly so for me it wasn’t that
warm as a couple was just in
professional productions
I because the Germans had already approved from the
outset
that I
would not go there and the whole thing  n
American there is of course
asked for everyone but there was also
this incentive for me that you so I
just wanted to get even better
I wanted
or should get even thinner I
should then have no idea anal with with
a [ __ ] perfectly master
best with  two or three double
penetrations then here this that and
sometimes that was just a
bit too much for me I
didn’t want it at all and
I just wanted to be more in my
own bage because I’ve
sometimes seen films like that, where then I have no
idea
some woman got kicked in the ass
like that and
I saw in her face that
she just doesn't like it and I didn't see
myself in the
situation because I just
didn't want it that
means you could have done the professional production but
you did  you stayed in my amateur area
and if you can consciously go
into it like that i think i
did  Almost every production is
asked for somehow, but it's also the thing
that they don't
pay nearly as much as you
could earn on an amateur platform with
a video you made yourself
and it's also like that, of course, you can do
all of your own  Image rights cede and you
don't have any decision
about it what does the thumbnail look like what was cut in
now and what not
do you like it there at the moment or
is it just supposed to be somehow different of
course the broad masses
probably don't notice that you're
yourself  I don't think it's nice right now
because the eighth then they think
everything's cool anyway if you're somehow just
on
the most satisfying
but that's maybe a bit of
a kind of professionalism that
you can just hand it over and
say okay I
accept
that they have all that and many
don't want to have anything to do with it at all, they do it
now  r
professional stuff and nothing
amateur-like at all because they don't
have to take care of it themselves, they go
there for an hour and a half
rather with the things next to their few thousand
euros and go back and then
see how it's never like that
again  I
don't care at all but it doesn't matter to me or it wouldn't have mattered
and are there any
talks or interest from
so-to-speak classic media to say
people come to RTL or to
ProSieben so in common
formats, so to speak, there's also one  Interest
because you are obviously a well-known person
in a
certain scene, of course, but this scene is
also somehow part of society, you
could have said you could go into
other formats now, so those that
are not so, so not so
adult formats is today's
topic  or was there interest? I'm getting
started for so many things
but mainly in the area  h
Youtube something about Funk or something like that with
any kind of question formats
where it is of course
always explicitly about porn and porn consumption and
other such things where there should be any kind of
discussion then
I always
stay
out of it very quickly and distance myself  me because
I don't want to convince anyone of
anything, so I don't want to be
told
why porn might be bad because that
in itself, well
, first of all I'm not blind and of
course I read myself and know the risks and
stuff like that, but I also want to  don't
want to try to convince someone
why what I
'm doing or what I've done is good, but
somehow
other people are doing it quite normally and I still see it
after I
've canceled, then someone else comes along
who was asked about it and
I think they always do it really well
but I never saw myself in this
German market and I was like
that until today we are
many not at all that I'm German at all
where I also think it
should maybe have
arrived slowly but
yes I was just so far away  I would say about what was
going on in Germany on the
sites or in this industry
and that's why I often
didn't want to speak for the Germans or
for the amateur porn in the
German scene because I was so
concerned with it  Yes, I don't know at all.
Maybe I didn't do something like that
.
A little bit about the
people still operate the platform and in
his exchange or do you have an overview of
how this platform is
developing? There's a lot of
discussion, but the role of
Credit card companies
, such constantly new discussions
, that's what we're following, what
you're getting into,
yes, of course, you notice something like that
because then you have to see whether it will
continue like this or not now for me in
my position it is of course
not that interesting anymore whether it
will be like that or not but it
will not be quite last year either that was
the biggest joke of all  when I
don't know if you noticed
that, but that was that credit card scandal
or not, so what exactly
happened there somehow, I'm
actually not that into pictures, but
then from one day to the next it was said that it was
n't a window either
no longer allows pornographic content
although they wrote
back to all sorts of people
before that for a week hey don't worry I would
happen and then I don't know
hundreds of thousands of
girls or boys and vida stood there and
had to be afraid that their
source of income would suddenly disappear from one
day  other way then they really wanted to
be some kind of white
influencer thing and because of that
i  everyone on Twitter complained so excessively
and then they also made such a
ridiculous tweet about they being
pro sex workers and stuff like that there
so they kept wondering that they
said well then, let’s do
pornographic stuff
again  it was really a huge joke
and at the time it was of
course so that you asked yourself
okay so where is the journey
going now you just don't know exactly if
the platform with the largest
monthly income suddenly
breaks down what  do you do
which platform do you switch to because you
are not involved at all
which platform is serious now which one
will establish itself the most so of course you
also want to access the platform
where most users are
do you think you will have to go
against it again one day  work for money or do you think
you could do that now you have already
earned so much and then you have the
videos and all that  Platforms
what summer is coming that might be enough
for the end of my life and you just have to
see that the videos continue to do well
and somehow invest the income well
that was it I hope and I strongly
assume that I won't have to go back to
work normally because that  even
since i can't
think my wish was i always wanted to
do what i like i did
n't want to have to listen to anyone else
and especially i didn't want to
dance after someone else's party and
i'm glad i can
make my own  way yes could create
what in many ways or from the eyes of
many is of course
very much worse way dirty
money you don't make of course everyone sees things
differently in hindsight I'm
still glad that I
did it tell me a few words about
your own shop  you have your
own shop and you
really
sell clothes
I then also order 100 or 100,000
yes
what you have now so do it
together with my I don't want to say
manager but
I did it together with Björn
who is called met because
I was actually looking for someone to
build my website and
yes right there  did all that and
then I noticed that he was
obviously also good at marketing in some way,
so he just has a
general idea of ​​all this stuff
and
when we released something again, it went
well, of course, that we
were able to tell about sales that weren’t in any way
outstanding
Of course it wasn’t like when
I had no idea bilou in the new shower foam,
so you can’t compare that at all
, but
I just don’t stress about things like
that because we did
n’t produce particularly large
quantities and I tend to do it a
bit first  go a little bit smaller
and see how things are going
I'll always say sorry
everything is sold out now instead of having
50,000 things printed and then
, legally, only 15,000 are
bought  is somehow
personalized videos of you that
somehow cost around 100 dollars
or that you follow people for 70 dollars
so if you followed me now on
Instagram that would give
me around 70 dollars for free yes
exactly so those are
things you have  then at some point
thrown into the room as a joke because of
course it is also requested and why
then not make a business model out of
it offer demand
yes so
sold so that the people that the
people follow is incredible it's
really a two for you
you didn't really have that now
let's say
hundreds sold a few
no, I always ask Björn really hard about the price
because I'm the one I think
so that it doesn't cost me and
that he made it quickly then
please let's sell 20 dollars here for no idea
I don't know and
then  everyone buys it, i always think to
myself and he says you ca
n't do it like that, i knew it was
somehow exclusive, i think to
myself, but like that, that's something
, maybe you can do someone who
doesn't or what do i know  who actually
somehow always put
a few euros aside for two
or three months and thinks so okay now no
longer at first and then I think to myself
well then let yourself be
treated to it for a small thaler so he's
just happy  about it and for me
there is no effort but like that I
think like that but with him it comes
out a bit like the
businessman what is the
difference you can indeed
nowadays  Hlich with with all sorts of stuff
just make money so that's
kind of just great
I would have talked to Bonnie Langen about the while she was
also relatively successful with only fans
and there was that in
the Badewasser she both sells what he
actually does  that was completely
unbelievable actually but
you wouldn't do things
like that I would do that before I somehow now Zuse actually wants to discuss everything I'm doing with Kevin because of course I don't want me
to do anything that offends them
or where  Discomfort feels good but so
yes, I think if that were okay for him it
would be absolutely okay for me
to sell my bath water because okay
then they should just throw themselves over with
the water where dead
skin from me is in it, so until then
it's not quite clear now
that I should breed myself again
, he'll be happy to do that, so socks
and under  It's
kind of common to
buy it because it's kind of a
fetish and why should
n't you use it, so I don't do it now
or not anymore, but of
course I did it and of course it went
quite well
[Music]
yes, absolutely, so we did it like that back
then, I didn’t know
wear it somehow and then made it again
like a kind of proof video
that had the advantage on the one hand
that they saw I was
really wearing it, on the other hand it had that
The advantage was that they had something personal in
their hands, so they knew the
person I bought something from, who
picked up the
cell phone especially for
me and made the video especially for me and
then I did it too
I also said the name of him so that he also knew that
it was for him and I can
imagine that it
was just like a way of life  such a
birthday greeting is bought but you
wear underpants
[music]
between 75 dollars and if you
somehow
regulated everything up so you could
still set different things
that sometimes just didn’t
cost two 300 dollars or so was
a nice side income
but it is  yes gratifying or totally
relaxed that you are not greedy now
that you can do without all this income
that you had again
that okay that was the way it is
now it
’s gone you don’t
trust it either but you just start a new chapter and that
’s it  sometimes it is so you have to be able to
let go but
many are not good at that and you can be
very good yes first of all thank you for the
compliment I am of the opinion
that greed will never bring you forward and
I know where I come from I just come from
I don't come from a rich family and I don't come from
somewhere where you're somehow
wasteful  and I'm also of
the opinion that if you then
want to have things together, you have to
somehow
work them out and I actually find it
completely unfair, for example,
how much I earn, so I find that
sometimes I
don't really look at my income and  I'm
supposed to think that's actually so
incredibly cheeky how I think I've
done it again this month even though
I haven't actually done anything
so we'll talk again now then we'll
talk about these several
10,000 euros something like that ne yes exactly about this
subscription model, not fans either  Of course
everyone can decide for themselves whether they
buy it or not because I
haven't been actively applying anywhere since now,
but that's how I keep it in the back of
my mind that in the best case scenario it's my
pension insurance that's what I'll practically do when I
retire at some point
when I'm old because I
don't
pay into life insurance every month  n but
I just have to make sure that I invest it
somewhere else
and hopefully then through the
investor also put several
more your parents are now cool with
the whole career so they
know all that and have good relationships with them they
are relaxed about
it  yes yes
yes that was also the case my mum is
always super sweet when
I tell her hey I was in the
living room for example or something like that then
she says oh man send it over here
I really want to take a look at it
and then I’ll send it to her  and then
she says
you've actually learned that
to talk so great how learned that what
do you mean kind of a course
that kind of I was something like that because
with you she's so well so in with you
there so in that in that  Scene next week,
hello, I'm all alone,
I've somehow grown up so much through this whole thing
,
um, someone doesn't know exactly what she
meant, but I do  next time
thanking and
through this I believe with
the coming success their
fears were taken away a bit because they then
also saw I just do
it with the person you were
familiar with at the time  I was
together and not in any way with what
I you can't see me in
and they also saw that I was
n't feeling bad or something
and if I somehow went to
my mom and said four
moms look I was here  currently
on number 1 worldwide at pornhub just
now meanwhile it has been for a
long time of course everything is super
relaxed so during all the successes you
never left Germany that you
have so to speak you can
live in Germany produce it in Germany
the biggest porn nope
No, I haven't been for ages, so
I haven't been in Germany for almost two years,
where exactly that's how you A  You
can only guess where I am
staying
but that's definitely nice or
you know it's better like a platform or
something of
course you don't want to lie there are
definitely tax advantages not
living in Germany
exactly I reserved the right
to say hey  I leave everything in
Germany and
have nothing to do with Germany anymore
and settle somewhere else where I
don't have to pay almost 50 percent tax
and yes, whatever
happens, in any case
, all the best, thank you very much  your time
for the conversation for the openness so I
have learned a lot about the world
and I am sometimes even
surprised with my pulse I have to say so you are
describing the next time
and take care with your parents
saying
this podcast is being produced  by
potsstars
at OMR